people of the internet welcome back to
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
it's been a while so welcome back hope
you all are doing well here's where
we're at in the game
you can see we have completed two of
what looks like there's going to be four
tasks here so we are on number three
right now
attend potions class in the dungeons to
learn about the wigan well potion so
that is where we will begin the
harry potter and prisoner of azkaban
adventure for today so as i said in the
beginning i hope you all are doing well
i know it's been a little bit since
we've done one of these so i'm excited
and looking forward to it today
now uh we just wrapped up thanksgiving
so hope you all had a wonderful
thanksgiving for those of you in the u.s
who celebrate thanksgiving that is so i
don't even know if i'm going the right
way to be honest it's been a while uh so
let's just go ahead and try to head this
way gun hilda of gorsmore corridor i
believe that's right but wait did i just
what's that what's that noise
is it this thing
ah there we go cauldron cake
and it looks like we do still need a
little bit of health on harry it's kind
of hard to see if you look i think kind
of around his head down there in the
bottom right corner you see that little
green bar i'm pretty sure that's our
health bar right there yeah there we go
you saw a little indicator kind of flash
red for a second there when we
maxed out the health so i'm gonna have
to keep an eye on that
yeah i guess it was the was the sound of
the cauldrons making a little
that little noise all right let's go
ahead and go through this corridor here
i'm pretty sure this is the right way
all right here we go
so we are back out in the main area
right now and it looks like uh it's just
ron
and me right now so we haven't reunited
with hermione just yet
which uh last time down in the comments
you guys were we were talking about
uh how you feel about the fact that some
characters have well all three of the
main trio here snape's going to be angry
if we're late oh well you know we're
definitely going to be late i mean
we're definitely going to be late
because the game probably wants us to be
late
yeah we were talking about how how you
guys feel about that and if you like it
or not
i like the idea i just think it's kind
of weird
what some of them are like the fact that
ron is just like for some reason really
good with uh
i hate to say this but we should go to
the dungeons oh my goodness ron i know
dude what you don't understand ron
is i'm harry my special ability is the
map
and i still can't figure out which way
to go because the map is
it's just not a very helpful map in this
game i gotta say okay wait are we just
supposed to go straight over this way
third floor corridor yes this gotta be
right i think all that study's getting
to hermione she said something about
going to double arithmancy
is now with us uh okay so they are gonna
i i was curious i couldn't remember how
the game handled
hermione's use of the time turner and
her classes and all that if they
mentioned it or not
but yeah i uh i i like the idea i just
think the the choice for harry and ron
is particularly kind of strange
hermione's makes a lot of sense though
the fact that she would get access to
certain spells that the other two can't
just because she's the best of the three
right in terms of
pure wizard ability first floor
transfiguration okay so let's see if
it's like the uh chamber of secrets game
oh dude
i wonder what we're actually supposed to
shoot up there incendio or something
but i think if i remember right isn't
hermione the only one who knows incendio
harry's got expelliarmus
and looks like nothing in those spots
flopindo and expelliarmus is all
harry has right now ron has
expelled the army's hypnos so ron has
the same thing all right let's go back
to the adventure here
it looks like it switched to ron's go
back to harry i really don't want to all
right so now we are officially in the
entrance hall
and if it's like the other games then
the way you get to the slytherin
dungeons is right over here
yep looks like here we go
and is this going to lead us dungeon
corridor
i think we're on the right track you
know going back and playing these games
and experiencing all the load screens i
know i point this out like every video
just because not because i want you guys
to know that i'm i'm skipping the
cutscenes for you
but just because when you watch these
videos back i don't think you fully you
don't fully realize just how
many load streams there are because i
kind of try and hide it with a little
transition if you're if you're a really
careful viewer then you probably catch
them sometimes but it's just like
there are so many loading screens in
these games so
the fact that i mean when hogwarts
legacy comes out it'll be the first
harry potter game we've had where
hopefully there's not any loading
screens and if there are i hope they are
much uh more spread out than what we see
in these games and i mean it has to be
right because these games were so
limited
in terms of the technology they had at
the time common injuries the more
attentive of you were we
what
weasley
bring him to the front
now
somehow harry's getting blamed for this
right
drag harry to the front of the glass
what
oh my goodness
the humiliation man
it's first of all stop messing about
i'm i'm bringing him oh my goodness dude
where do you want him like right in
front of the table here mr weasley
if you pay attention you might actually
okay something i'm trying pick up both
vials of wigan world potion from the
table okay
pick up both files
pick up the vibe congratulations mr
weasley you actually managed to do what
i asked
why minister the wigan weld potion to
yourself
stand away from potter okay drink the
contents of one of the vials
okay
drink it okay he tells me to drink it he
doesn't even tell you how okay wait
wrong pause button
it's so annoying like i gotta remember
it's the menu button z
okay so it goes into this little area
right here replenishes lost stamina we
actually have to equip this
no way come on and it's going to take
the place of
dude
that is so annoying
so annoying got to take the place of one
of those spells okay
y mr malfoy
now stand close to potter and administer
the potion okay stand close to potter
administer the potion
is it gonna work though like i just
settle down mr malfoy all right here we
go
i'm pressing it nothing's happening
give the potion you have to be just like
right beside him i thought i was close
enough but apparently not
i will let mr weasley give you a full
explanation
incompetence speaks for itself i mean
that was pretty like i i gotta i kind of
gotta agree with snape on that one you
know
we no longer have time for the rest of
the lesson
so
you will now be gathering the
ingredients for the antidote to uncommon
poisons in your own time
ready for my next lesson
interesting for the next class therefore
you are to bring fire seeds billy wick
stings do we actually have to go and get
this
and
the horn of a grab horn say what
glass dismissed
dude the horn of a grab horn
and of course there was another loading
screen
i'm really sorry
don't worry let's go outside
well
i'm exhausted
yeah
me too
i think we should turn in yes harry's
like let's go outside you should start
looking for those potion ingredients but
what do you think carrie
harry
what
why is he like just
okay
so we have no task and we can't end the
day
all right that's really strange okay so
let's
how do i is there a way i can reference
all of those now i will say that is
something a little bit different that
the other games haven't done i really
like the fact
that something you do in class
is actually going to kind of carry over
so it's not
in the other games it's like the classes
were just sort of one-off right like you
go to the class you do this thing and
that's that's it
uh this one okay if you wish to stop
exploring a move well it wouldn't let me
end the day but there's some stuff up
there
we need to try and figure out how to
turn in
yeah ron relax dude hermione said we
should probably
what is that
right there
are those wicked well potions over there
okay let's switch to hermione because
oh yeah i think can she do that little
glacies
i can't think of anything else to do ron
oh my god dude that is going to get on
my nerves
so much with this game
so much with this game but see what i
don't like about this right here is the
fact that that bottom one is there but
it's empty
it's almost like there is something else
you could do
okay apparently there's no confirm
the a button is grayed out
but apparently it works and there's no
confirm when you want to end the day
awful love oh my goodness gryffindor
slytherin just dominant right now
gryffindor is in the lead oh wait what i
thought slytherin was like 170 or
something
i continued to worry about the dementors
of sirius black that scene you guys you
saw the loading screen before and ever
as well
you've got to help neville what
neville was wandering around on the
fifth floor and malfoy's lot found him
and locked him in the muggle studies
classroom locked in the mug and they've
released a ghoul where's hermione in the
girl's dormitory she's finding it easy
to study up there
well i suppose it's you and me sled
hermione's study it's cool it's cool
we'll take care of it
alright so let's go and see if we can
prefect bash last seen in the entrance
hall i do want to go and look for that
as well
but i got a feeling
that they're not gonna make that easy
not gonna make that easy considering uh
apparently they've released a ghoul or
something so
all right let's see if ron's health is
fully restored yeah it is so that we can
world potion
and that's interesting look at that it
actually uh
re-applied the expelliarmus to the y
button so since i ran out of the wigan
well i really should be helping neville
really should be helping neville where
what did they say fifth floor i think
okay can i why can't i not lock on the
pots that's so weird
okay no loading screen right there
for whatever reason they don't need to
load on that one
all right so
we're sneaking out after hours i guess
because
never got locked in somewhere
muggle studies that's right that's where
he is pretty sure they said the fifth
floor
yep there we go fifth floor dude you
know something so weird about the word
fifth
this is just a complete random tang by
the way but that's what these let's
plays are all about right i mean
that's the point of watching let's plays
you know
at least let's plays with commentary
okay hold on we'll have to wait we'll
have to wait on that thought with with
the word fifth
looks like we got to do battle with the
malfoy here
uh
pull and hold r to target an opponent
and then cast
ron is like already about to go down
dude what is happening
i'm not feeling too good
can i use expelliarmus
[Music]
come on change the lock on oh goodness
no
there you go ron got another one
just get right here and spam
he's down there we go
and there's a chocolate frog
see i like the idea of those little
encounters like that
controls are just so wonky
controls are incredibly wonky and and
just trying to lock on and figure out
okay there's chocolate frog
dude look at all this stuff can i like
oh
did that just
i think i just killed ron
i think ron is done
oh no what do i do
can i like do i have to drag him
i think he just has to stay there i
guess
i thought that
i don't know what i thought dude i
thought that was like some sort of power
up inside there yeah see this one looks
like a little little clock right here
can i not break that one oh dude and
there's a cup on top of that
look at this man
is that hufflepuff's cup
did they hide a horcrux right here in
plain sight
all the way back in the prisoner of
azkaban game now see like i wonder if
i'm supposed to try and get that somehow
because did you see it it kind of
bounced for a second
yeah right there bounced again
dude i don't know i wonder if you could
if you could move these around like if i
could push this over
see that's like these older games i'm
probably thinking way too hard there's
probably no way for me to do that and
looks like ron is back with us now he
just like fainted for a while and has
very minimal health so he's basically
one hit he's not gonna be any help to us
at all going forward here
let's go and open this chest right here
but yeah the word fifth like
i don't know why all of a sudden that
word just when i say it it sounds so
weird
i feel like everyone when they say the
word they say fifth
fifth
like fourth
fifth
and i don't know i don't know why like
i'm just now realizing this but
what do you think when you say fifth out
loud and you actually make sure you
really get that f in the middle right
there
oh goodness what in the world
is this the ghoul
i don't know dude probably just me
probably
it's just one of those weird words that
like all like sometimes you say words
like your entire life and then all of a
sudden you you read it or you write it
down that happens a lot you know you
write it down you're like that spelling
doesn't look correct what doesn't look
like that word at all
and then you look it up and it's
actually the correct way to spell it
dude why is a guitar attacking me
can i go ahead and open this chest i
hope there's some health in here
or a wizard card oh it's another one of
those uh
i forgot somebody in the comments told
me what those are
and i completely forgot
there we go
because the game literally just doesn't
tell you like they just straight up
don't even bother like you'll figure it
out
all right let's make sure there's not
anything
let me get something out of there
maybe
maybe no
no all right fine
okay let's see if we can figure out we
need to get we really need to get ron
some health
so it looks like our health is
definitely not shared so
if i see a cauldron cake or something or
a chocolate frog i need to switch off of
harry
and go grab it with ron instead let's go
ahead and move forward here
now the load screen just leave me no
actually not
oh is that the ghoul
dude that thing is creepy
stop that it's not doing any good oh my
gosh
stop that it's not doing any good okay
well what am i supposed to do in here
but i can't open it let me try that
there's something in here i can't open
it oh we gotta use ron's secret ability
well uh do we like just not care about
this
ghoul did we just
not care about it okay
what is he doing
oh my goodness he's throwing stuff
neville
oh wow okay so there's there's got to be
like a hidden corridor or something in
here
this right here this little platform
nope
should be something against the wall
right
so we're just like ignoring that ghoul
are we cool with that okay i guess he's
not actually going to attack us or do
anything
search this box
there's something in the box
oh it's from the uh
ridiculous lesson okay i wonder if we
see that later
i wonder if we see that later on
or if they just thought that's kind of a
cool way to sprinkle something from the
movie in there
oh great okay so now is when
what is this
what is this toy story
and ron is down okay it just refilled
his health nice that's big
so if i go down while he is the
controlled character
then it just instantly refills itself
okay what am i supposed to do with these
things okay there we go finally
are you sure there's nothing up there
i'm looking just give me a second
there's birdie bop beans let me go ahead
and go through this door
okay good no loading screen right there
watch there'll be one after this
that would be hilarious there's like
literally just a door and then another
door something in here i can use okay
something in here that we can use to
hopefully a spell book
oh a new spell let's go
now is this gonna be unique to ron i
wonder or is it also gonna
pass to harry
is this fred and george's secret stash
or something
what in the world
what is that thing
i didn't even press that button but okay
it's trying to lock on
for some reason r locks on in this game
oh there's another cup okay
dude
what wait did i actually learn a new
spell i bet that's why it took me to the
menu
i bet that's why let's see here
did i totally miss it yes i did right
here lumos duo one lighting charm
conjures a focused light beam from the
end of the wand interesting so is it
going to be more
like what lumos is supposed to be like
oh no
oh wait you gotta hold it down
reveal yourself he's doing something
it's like burning these things
okay you can't just tap it you actually
have to hold it down
reveal
now what do i flip into him now
are you serious okay there's another one
over here
let's get this one out of the way he's
kind of like isolated on his own right
now
and i don't even know how close i'm
supposed to be i guess this is good
enough
dude this is ridiculous he's gonna faint
again in here
what is this gameplay man is this like
luigi's mansion or something okay maybe
we actually can do it from pretty far
away
all right dodge out of the way
okay you cannot hit a to dodge while
you've got the
light beam going
yeah see i feel like nothing's happening
when i'm this far away
so we have to get in close on them oh
wait
is this gonna help us
can i turn it again
no okay that goes back the way i came
okay let's just drop it right there
now can i like shine the light on here
wait maybe shine the light on this thing
you move the camera around
okay maybe shine the light through it on
the other side oh wait it's this eyeball
right
was that something to do with the
eyeball
oh
dude
oh wait maybe i need to light these can
i light those with
with shining the light on it
oh my goodness he's about to die again
but luckily it like doesn't even really
penalize
oh you can't keep turning it
okay did it
intentionally pull me
dude i i really don't know which way
they want me to turn this thing
oh he no it pulled me out because he
actually got hit
dude this is so bizarre
okay i feel like there's something with
that little orb over there
maybe
this orb right here no
okay that orb apparently does nothing
but if we shine
and there are are these chalkboards or
mirrors i think they're just
all right i'm just gonna get right up on
one again because that was definitely
doing something
maybe we're not supposed to worry about
the puzzle until after we get rid of
these guys
oh wait oh wait oh wait
now he's already back what
are you serious right now
we have to get them all together
and then he's then he's done like
he doesn't even
stay frozen for very long
okay we're like keeping that guy like he
that guy is locked right now
okay there we go
that's what i tried to do before and
nothing happened
i think he just came free too quickly
earlier
okay there we go one more one more
where's he at
let me at him
this is the strangest mechanic
like see that one just didn't hit
i was still locked on
for whatever reason
get behind him maybe
apparently again
i didn't do something right that time
they didn't like something
i'm gonna hold it extra long this time
are you kidding me dude
oh my goodness is there four this time
no don't hit
just
me
wait wait wait blast him
hey there we got that one
no we didn't he's already free again
dude why are these guys getting free
right here
just gonna hold it if you hold it that
extra like let him
it's like when they're about to come
free
then let go then do it there we go we
got two of them right there and this
one's just for whatever reason he's just
relaxing here i'm not gonna question it
i'm not gonna complain about it
finally
oh my goodness so was that the cool or
was the other thing the cool how do i
get out of here
continually shining lumos on crystal
balls will charge them with light well
uh yeah that wasn't working
when the ghouls or whatever they were
were hanging out
because i tried that
right now it's turn and has it turned
the right way
no we need to get it to face that little
eyeball over there
or at least reflect to the eyeball there
we go perfect
all right so did we actually obtain
anything in here that helped us was it
lumos is that what we picked up here
all right fine okay let's move on let's
grab these points for gryffindor
and we shall continue
let's see
what a weird weird little encounter
it's like so many of the things so far
in this game
i like their ideas
i just don't love the execution of a lot
of it oh yeah ron definitely needed that
nicely done
all right now we're back to uh toy story
up here
i thought we took care of the
of the ghouls
oh my goodness there's enough there's a
rubber duck
tell me harry what exactly is the
function of a rubber duck
dude i want you know they put that in
here for that reason they're like we
gotta throw a rubber duck in there just
because me just because mr weasley was
so curious about rubber ducks
but then again they do have just like
all sorts of ram like airplanes and uh
we had the
jack in the box
earlier ron we need your help down here
yep you guys have been holding it down
right
okay i never expected to be doing battle
against the robot
firing missiles in a harry potter game
but here we are
oh he's just winding up dude he is mad
he is mad
look at that though dodged out of the
way of those
i got a feeling i'm not doing something
right
oh i think i have to hit him like right
when he was opening up
there we go only hit him once right
there
so i guess i should just stop firing
every single moment
right
now
and dodge
oh i thought it sounded like he was
opening up again
dude he's got like some armor on there
right there
dodge dodge
what one more hit maybe
two possibly i think one should do it
[Music]
nice there we go
like just such bizarre encounters but i
kind of like it actually
i kind of like that one
all right so we got a little train up at
the top we've got the airplane flying
around still
is that one of those uh orbs we can
charge up
can i grab that first there we go
all right let's charge this up
don't really know what's gonna happen
when we do
oh perfect straight to the light
straight to the light opens that up for
harry
switch to harry now and let's see what's
inside here
absolutely nothing
dude wait are we supposed to trap this
guy in here is that what we're supposed
to do
stop that it's not doing any good
wait a second
what is in there
see i feel like i was gonna try to like
lure him in here
stop that it's not doing any good
oh maybe the new spell will work on the
ghoul okay so we just want him to come
down here now then what's the point of
that room
there we go we're gonna like force him
back into there
so this is the ghoul i don't know what
those other guys were then
all right now what we need to somehow
make it close on him
leave my friends alone nicely done ron
okay
let's get back to the common room kind
of making up for your little uh
your stupidity earlier in the potions
classroom
all right so we got neville with us now
all right let's go dude can i switch to
neville no
all right but i want to see just did
harry also learn the lumo spell because
if he didn't
if he didn't learn lumos as well that's
just weird man
that's just weird if he did not learn
lumos
are you serious he didn't
oh my goodness man that is so
like that i don't like like ron should
not have lumos and harry doesn't
can we go back hermione have access to
some special spells yes absolutely i
think that's fine i think that makes
perfect sense but harry not having asset
access to lumos not only a spell he
definitely had as a real wizard during
this time in the books but also a spell
that he had in the last game
in book two
go back to the common room now all right
i got a feeling that something's gonna
prevent us from doing that
as easily as we would like and i also
just notice
why can i not spin the camera around
i just need to go to bed can we go now
see the other thing is like it makes it
so difficult to tell
that one has a lock on it and i don't
think we have alohomora do we
hermione does but we don't okay yeah
that's what they look like when they're
when they're opened up
so this one has most definitely not been
opened
dude ron why are you whining so much man
get a grip
like what i just want to go to bed
like who when they were programming this
game thought let's set the timer
to like every
five seconds
if you don't progress towards the goal
ron or snape or whoever
whoever you're around at the time is
going to bug you incessantly
until you make progress where you're
supposed to go
it's just ridiculous man
it's just insane i can't get over it and
like they they don't encourage
exploration at all like i would love to
just kind of look around here make sure
i've explored everything but i know if i
take even an extra couple seconds can we
go back now please
i mean it doesn't take long dude it
doesn't take long
we need to find her
oh the fat lady's gone
[Music]
poor thing
did she say who did it
oh yes professor he got very angry when
she wouldn't let him in you say
nasty tempo he's got that serious black
dude
and how awesome is that moment in the
buzzword
we'll be standing in for the fat lady
when you know he's in hogwarts i know
you're all still very welcome
what's happened but my advice would be
for you all to go to bed
oh thanks mcgonagall we're not worried
at all not concerned in the slightest
that an apparent mass murderer is on the
loose
not concerned at all and we didn't even
get to look for that prefect badge did
we because every time i try and look for
anything
mr weasley here
is too worried about going to bed
or getting to our next checkpoint
all right let's see return to griffith
common room and i think i mean i think
we can end the day right i don't think
there's anything else to
let's just go ahead and hit a and see
what happens
of course right blowing his assault on
the fat lady but with their first ever
care of magical
doesn't have a normal person's view of
what's dangerous indeed
i'm sure it'll be fine let's get to the
class early so that we can give hagrid
some support it's his first lesson and
he's probably more nervous than we are
you know i gotta say man i feel it's
been a while since i read all the books
but i feel like most of haggard's
lessons were
actually pretty solid
i mean there were a couple that you're
kind of like eh
probably not the best idea hagrid but
for the most part i feel like you did a
pretty good job i mean i think of the
nifflers i think of buckbeak even though
buckbeak's lesson went bad like that one
totally wasn't his fault oh there's sir
duggan
look at him man
yeah
just when you read that book for the
first time like you kind of know at some
point sirius black is either going to
come to hogwarts or
there wouldn't be such a focus on him in
the beginning of that book
if if he wasn't going to somehow impact
the story and make it to hogwarts but
when you when you get to that moment
when you
actually
know that he was there oh so good
all right that's the north wing
is that where i just came from
hold on i just want to see what's over
here i don't let ron
let ron just run his mouth all he wants
i really want to explore and see what's
over here for a second well we've got a
moment
dude what is this this looks like a
giant map right here
check out what's over here
like see i would love to just look
around all this
[Music]
we really should be going
you too harry you too
all right fine let's go
doesn't look like there's really
anything to do in this area anyway
that's the other thing that it's going
to be really key when when hogwarts
legacy releases is
how alive does the castle feel right and
if you just
if you go down some random corridor
obviously you would hope it'll be laid
out so much better than this one
uh fat ladies corridor right there so we
need to go this way
grand staircase all right
all right let's make our way down and
you know what while we're down here
i know it said that prefect badge was in
the entrance hall right
so let's kind of look around down there
and see if we can't find it
i love how the game just randomly puts
you in control of hermione too
like no specific reason just beer you're
in hermione control of hermione now why
are we going outside
it could be a spell that we don't have
access to yet i didn't think about that
let's see under the stairs anywhere no
oh you know what it could also be it
could be ron let's see if hermione
learned lumos
now that will be really interesting if
she didn't
no she doesn't so yeah only ron knows
that one and only she knows uh glacious
right here
so let's go ahead and turn it on see if
we can uh
do anything with that right there
nope all right let's switch over to ron
dude why does it keep automatically
i didn't mean to do that keeps
automatically switching back to uh
expelliarmus at y every time
even when i because what i would like to
do if they're gonna have it like this we
should
we should have each character with
different spells mapped
outside
and that way i could just sort of hop
between each character when i'm trying
to uh
do different spells and stuff oh birdie
bop bean
how about this one
oh wiggin weld
like why can't i i hate that you can't
walk on to the little pots she's so
strange
okay this is actually the area they
consider the entrance hall so we'll we
will look around a bit here before we
i'm sorry to say it but all that
studying you're doing can't be healthy
if you're not careful
outside
you know i appreciate your concern it's
not a secret passage or something
almost nothing
okay that's a little weird
shouldn't we be going outside yep we
probably should but you know what i
don't care
that's got to be my top
complaint for for this game right now
dude
has to be
i mean just ridiculously annoying
i mean every
it's got to be like 10 15 seconds
it feels that's what it feels like
anyway we need to go
every time dude every time right on cue
dude where is this prefect badge
and why are there some areas that are
just completely blocked off
i'm actually surprised that it let me
even go into the great hall
first team to knock all their opponents
out wins wait what the heck is this
is this like dueling club or something
what
did the game tell me about this
and i just completely ignored it
what is going on and why is this in the
great hall
oh i just hit harry
and then i got hit by the pumpkin head
oh no dude we're getting we're getting
absolutely destroyed right now
there you go dodge
dodge dude i want the spell that turns
him into a jack lantern
frame rate is garbage right now grab
this potion
dude i don't want to lock on the hair oh
that's not hairy oh that was hairy right
there
oh no harry's down and hermione is is
almost down
oh we got this hermione we got this 2v1
2v1 oh no we're both we're both trapped
right now though we're both trapped
nice gryffindor wins
let's go
grab this
potion
okay that's pretty cool is that what
this is we can well
let's see let's see how many we have
because i just picked up like at least
five okay yeah ten nice
so that's gonna be
really handy let's switch to everybody
and see if they're back to full health
they are indeed
well that's interesting i had no idea
this was here maybe the game told me
earlier
and i totally forgot about it i don't
know
but you know what guys i think that's
going to be a great place to stop next
time we'll pick back up and we will
resume looking for that prefect badge
and then we'll head out to care of magic
creatures with hagrid so thank you all
so much for watching and i will talk to
you again very soon